This episode of DNews is brought to you by
Canon PIXMA Pro professional inkjet printers:
Exactly as you envisioned.
3D printers have come a long way just in the
last few months; we're getting to a point
where I'm going to have to ask "what CAN'T
we print?"
Printing is not dead.
Not at all.
Midway through the last century, futurists
began to predict the death of paper, and they're
still wrong.
In fact, we seem to be in a new industrial
age, where tiny factories can sit on your
desk next to your paperclips…
I definitely don't have paperclips anymore.
3D printing has spurred a whole new creative
generation of makers.
People who design and "print" their own creations
to satisfy curiosity, specific needs or even
SCIENCE!
3D printers are getting more varied, last
month, the World Advanced Saving Project unveiled
a printing robot which constructs whole houses
out of materials readily available in impoverished
countries: mud and natural fibers.
Construction of this type has been common
for the millenia, and because the robot uses
triangles instead of solid bricks, the houses
are both stronger, and require less mud.
It can build houses 10 feet (3M) tall using
only materials found on site -- so they're
FREE.
They say they got inspired by the potter wasp,
which builds it's houses of mud and fibers.
YET ANOTHER BIOMIMICRY EXAMPLE!
Speaking of copying nature though, a lot of
the 3D printing craze is prosthetics.
Also last month, this 3D printed prosthetic
hand was created by the Range of Motion Project
who work in Guatemala and Ecuador.
Using 3D printers and electromyographic electronics,
students from the University of Illinois Urbana-Champaign
can create a prosthetic hand that senses the
sensory feedback from the brain and translates
it to movement in the hand.
It can be custom created in a little over
a day for about 270 bucks and, with use, learns
more than the five motions in its original
programming.
The researchers say thanks to 3D printing
technology, they were able to prototype YEARS
sooner than with traditional manufacturing.
It can even respond with electrical signals
back into the ARM!!
It's not all plastic hands and mud houses
though.
Remember when they spent years learning to
grow ears on the backs of rats?
Now, researchers at University College London,
3D print structures using biological 'ink.'
Using the ear as an example, they can scan
an ear, and then use a 3D printer -- create
a plastic cellular scaffold.
They implant the scaffold under the skin of
the patient's arm, skin grows over it and
fills in the space with blood vessels and
tissue.
The ear is then attached to the side of the
head! Bam! 3D printed ear!
They believe it won't be too long before people
can print the organs without implanting them
first.
They can already grow some biological tissues
in the lab, included bone, skin and vascular
sections.
It won't be long now.
According to research firm Gartner, 3D printer
sales are going to double each year for the
next three.
By 2018, there could be almost two-and-a-half
million 3D printers out there.
This could be the tipping point, and the future
so bright, I might have to print some shades.
We’d like to thank Canon for making this
episode possible.
With Canon PIXMA Pro Professional inkjet printers,
you can expect a level of quality and accuracy
that keeps each print true to your unique
vision.
All backed by Canon's commitment to provide
professionals with fast, high quality service
you can depend on.
Have you 3D printed?
Do you want to try it?
Send us your 3D printed creations!